perfect trick shot an astounding feat of
human ability timed with perfectly
calculated physics sometimes they're so
incredible they're almost unhuman and
that got us thinking could a computer do
it better in this video we'll be doing a
three trick Gauntlet I'll be using
hundreds of thousands of years of
primate Evolution to complete the
gauntlet in real life and Jordan will be
using hundreds of thousands of dollars
of Cutting Edge CG technology to
complete the gauntlet on his computer
for the ultimate Man vs machine Showdown
now whoever completes the gauntlet first
will be the ultimate winner but there's
one caveat in honor of the world's most
perfect dudes and because neither of us
have completed the challenge yet we
cannot honorably use the words dude or
perfect at any point during The Gauntlet
if you do you will have to complete a
classic beer pong shot in order to
continue said Gauntlet all right Jordan
are you ready oh I was born ready good
luck sir good luck brother
good or cream
look here's the situation we have
perfectly built this physical world in
digital space we photo scanned the trick
shot Gauntlet and prepared it for
simulation inside of Houdini I only have
two rules one I cannot move any of the
objects in the scene and two I can only
take one shot at a time I will not be
animating these balls I will be using
real physics to get these balls into Sid
cups and through said Hoops just like
you do in real life except Mine mine's
the evolution of the perfect dude look
as admirable as computer technology is
it's no substitute for what the human
eye is capable of achieving the ability
to perceive something with our two front
eyes and to throw accurately in real
time to hit a Target and all I'm here to
do is to display it for the world to see
you know Jake is so focused on the human
form but Wally has shown us the future
Wally has shown us what the perfect
person looks like get me my chair get me
a hose for some grub and let me get to
work all right the first section is the
ping pong Apple Box challenge okay you
have to sit here and you have to take
your ping pong it has to bounce across
all three apple boxes and in to the lens
shaped mug at the end good luck and
remember watch that tongue I do oh
I I say do and perf a lot so I'm
actually a little nervous about this one
millions of years of human evolution
have led to this
one begin
that is just hone in hone in hone in
hone in I'm dealing with a very complex
set of boxes that need to be hit just
right crap he's going so much faster
than I expected okay
is he almost freaking Mega I've even
started okay okay so I'm giving it some
initial velocity basically I'm just
telling it how fast to move and what
direction we'll go negative one one
we'll just hone this in real quick there
we go that's the right direction now I
know I'm not going into it here but if
you guys are interested in how I made
this 3D environment there's a 48 minute
breakdown that covers everything from
the building to the rigging to the
simulation and everything in between
it's a really great watch if it sounds
like something you'd like check out
Corridor digital.com it's live right now
and there's a free trial I'm worried
about this one the most because it
requires like multiple bounces the other
ones are just like a straight velocity
shot which I can dial in I think a lot
easier but this is like I need to get it
to back oh bro I'm actually nervous now
yes perfect thank you
oh
I got three bounces Bang Bang
boom
tickling the rim brother
[Applause]
oh
my god
let's get ribs over there too he's
getting freaking rims over there
oh it's so close
what if I change the bounce of the Box
just on the last one so everything will
stay the exact same
are you freaking kidding me dude what is
this oh what's that dude anything dude
[Applause]
this freaking thing is stupid
where's my good one you're my good one
if I could dynamically change the
physics of the ball mid-bounce maybe I
can make it so it makes it all the way
to the cup and then just well
just rolls in there I will set the
bounce to be what it is right now and
then I will keyframe that so that the
frame before
it goes in the cup it has a bounce of
zero brother if this works let me tell
you she really set this to one
and I should get the same results I get
a different result of course I do
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you feel horrible
no this part of the chorus is called
rolling Mark you have to take a Nerf gun
and you have to shoot through the Rings
hit the marker knocking the Slate down
for your mark
it's not over yet we are back in three
two one go ah okay we're going up to
three I'm gonna do freaking three steps
I don't care we need we need precision
oh it's changed it's changed everything
he's already gone freaking closed
so much way too much one point two five
gosh every shot is a shot of the heart
that reload is exactly what I need
reload you don't have to I don't have to
reload maybe my finger's always cocked
and ready to rock no
goodness gracious I know what's annoying
is I keep doing the same thing dude am I
insane did you say dude oh
ah
what are you doing I hate you five
second rule one second rule keep yelling
it's chaos Jordan calm down calm down
you've done this a million times
it's all good baby
I mean no rush
[Music]
Jake has to end with the hardest one
just remember that no no no no I hit the
mark but I didn't hit the Rings I needed
to hit closer okay so I need to just
dial it back ever so slightly
1.75 why is this not dude I was so close
before
he's like the third time you said it oh
and I suck at this game too
oh
[Music]
yeah I got it are you freaking kidding
me
what am I doing for the peace De La
Resistance we have the classic ladder
fall you're going to be standing up
there at the top of the balcony and with
a tennis ball you have to hit it off all
three Apple boards and into the light
cone to complete the challenge here's
the reality this is the hardest one this
is one I was nervous about from the
start if I get through this I feel like
I'll move way way quicker and this is
the hardest one for him this one has
been the most challenging so I'm just
gonna try to work through it work
through it slow Just Dial Dial and all
set ready in three two one go
oh my God
don't even think about it
[Applause]
oh the hype Crews arrived my people
my people
I do it for the people I don't do it for
me 12 50 12 50 12 50 12 much money
riding on you I'm putting probably a
hundred dollar redues the meat man don't
miss okay it's not bouncing enough but
now the trajectory is not right so we
need more I need more like initial
velocity but if I just do minus point
two huh is that crazy a downward Force
oh
do you see how freaking close that is
[Applause]
oh
my gosh I mean I just hit the rim a
moment ago so what I'm doing is working
it's just a matter of chance do you have
any wind in yourself because there's no
there is a slight gust of wind in the
studio so theoretically you could have
that draft just pushing the slightly
that way right you're not wrong actually
wind yeah wind is consistent
wow that's why that's so windy it's
crazy too windy I need I need air
resistance I need air resistance there
we go that's what we want it we want it
right here
[Music]
yeah
so while Jake and I are busy striving
for Perfection I want to introduce you
to something that already found it baby
it's today's sponsor raycons not only is
it a perfect vessel for funneling sweet
sweet sounds into your ears it's also a
perfect price point so you don't break
the bank they're more affordable than
other premium earbuds they got
everything you could ever want there's
three customizable sound profiles earbud
tap functions noise isolation awareness
mode custom gel tips for the perfect
most comfortable in-ear fit and they got
colors for everybody the earbuds eight
hours unimpeded play time and if they do
die no worries man rechargeable battery
case just plug them in and just wait a
little bit they're charging literally
right now just wait a little bit look
the lights on and these aren't just
perfect for me they're perfect for Jake
too because he's going to be sweating by
the end of the competition and these are
water resistant which is ironically
perfect for Tears as well I'll have both
of those going so if you're a big crier
or you just find yourself in a wet
landscape hey Seattle raycons if this
sounds good to you and you want to get a
pair of your own head to byraycon.com
Corridor crew for 15 off our little gift
to you link in the description below now
where was I
I knew they'd get it eventually gentle
all right move on to the next one quick
now I just gotta aim and fire baby aim
and fire my main advantage here is that
my cycle my green uh little tape thing
here is time based consistent right so I
can dial in a shot so with perfect
repeatability why are you not winning
yet I think it's because Dude Perfect
wouldn't do it with an automatic gun
s
why do they say the whole thing I love
how he can't help himself he just has to
say it can't believe how much I say this
word it's in his DNA
come on
come on they can't stop me
[Music]
I gotta aim slightly for the left side
of the second block
[Music]
come on champ how is that going down I
don't know figure it out how does that
make any sense so I need a little a
little bit of uh tilt up a little built
up
okay okay okay okay okay okay so we can
see clearly that this is going through
it's skin in it
bro it wants to freaking do it don't it
wait wait to confirm we have to confirm
we have to confirm we're gonna save this
we're gonna catch it real quick that
means it's locked it's locked in there
look at how slow this is going dude
[Music]
this is going so slow
[Applause]
just I'm paying a king I'm panicking
[Music]
I'm gonna throw up I'm gonna throw up
thank you okay
[Applause]
we're gonna tie it up now
go go go go go go go go go
[Applause]
I'm gonna have a heart attack
okay I'm gonna say cup cup zero bounce I
want it to just fall flat limb dead
we're gonna give it a missile of one
okay okay I need minus 10 on y I'm gonna
bounce this thing here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go okay
I'm thinking we got we got direction
right we're gonna freaking do this thing
dude we're gonna freaking do this thing
okay so I need a little more bounce I
need a little more bounce he's got 20
people down there helping him
get out of there
maybe VFX we're stronger together
unionized freaking Commonwealth cheaters
don't do that
oh
that was so freaking close don't change
yo don't change too much don't change a
thing last one needs a little bounce huh
come on champ
what is it
that went in that went in
Dude Perfect
[Music]
we hit Rim shots like seven times before
that it was only a matter of time dude
look where I was dude I was
there bro I'm just so glad that I won
because I would never hear the end of it
a Wally future has been shot
about the future of mankind and that
hurts to say
I knew you wouldn't get it
what I thought was gonna happen was I
was gonna get these two and then you
were going to come from behind me and
you almost started dude I almost do you
want to go nuts here let me show you
come over here
no no I was there dude
I was there yeah and once you get close
it's a lot easier for you to make it I
thought I had you I was I was dialed in
man this was a ton of fun I think we
should do another one so fun and I gotta
say just for me it's an honor to meet a
perfect dude oh thank you so much
wow let's do another one holy smokes if
you guys have any other ideas for trick
shots that you want us to do in the next
iteration of this thing leave a comment
down below this was so much fun I almost
had an artifact I'm gonna go to the
hospital but then we'll do it when we
get back we'll read the comments I
promise see you later
all right Jordan gets one last try he
can change one more setting I'm not
risking that there's nothing for me just
to see I got one shot of this one
opportunity to see everything I ever
wanted in one moment it's been an honor
it's been an honor Jordan
thank you